[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la prévention est tellement mal fait en
france qu'il faut agir avec des gros
symbole c'est pour ça qu'on a on capote
et la place le message est simple c'est
sida que c'est cette hécatombe
[Musique]
une vingtaine de personnes a bloqué la
circulation pendant un quart d'heure il
reproche au président de la république
de ne pas s'être rendu à la conférence
internationale des organisations non
gouvernementales de lutte contre le sida
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je crois qu'il faut dire que l'église en
france est une entrave direct à la
prévention
l'église condamne le préservatif alors
que c'est le seul moyen de sauver des
vies à l'époque actuelle
je crois que l'église a une attitude
très discriminatoires envers les
séropositifs et les malades
[Musique]
l'humiliation extrême pour le docteur
habib sy sentiment de haine du côté des
militants d'act up
l'opération est spectaculaire
act up c'est une machine de guerre donc
comme comme une arme et il fallait
c'était très structuré il y avait tout
un teint une préparation des
manifestations des actions il y avait
plusieurs réunions par semaine pour pour
définir quelles cibles comment pourquoi
cette fois ci on utilise du sang
pourquoi cette fois ci on utilise des
cendres qui est ce qu'on va cibler
comment va on va parler aux médias
[Musique]